[Music]  when those seats are filled and when the  lights go down there is that moment  suspended in time we're waiting for the  magic to begin  [Music]  they cut you all I need is a shot you  guys ever need a piano players not in 30  years  Mira is art choreographer sander rains  you missed a ton I don't need to see it  again  I can do the turn fine  [Music]  Oh an audition for your show whoops of  deli  we need a stars under dawn says the star  I can't put that on the marquee okay  I'll sign the deal she'll be starring in  free Dawn's I need you to help me with  her to make this show work they're  called backup dancers because they're  always one step behind the star I need  to show to be certain I'm lonely  brilliant I want that too she's  phenomenal what exactly is going on  between you and Xander so she bared her  soul out there for you today  [Music]  to the top  you're strong you're very talented prove  yourself  [Music]  you